Wir wollen blicken auf den internationalen Fußball der Männer. Heute mit dabei, zumindest in der ersten Aufnahme, Spanien und Italien, was alles noch kommt. Ich weiß es selbst, zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht. Guckt in die Show Notes, wenn ihr es nicht wissen wollt oder hört doch einfach die ganze Folge. Jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und Hallo und herzlich Willkommen Fabian Pakulat. Servus Fabian, schön, dass du da bist. Guten Morgen. Schön, dass du es geschafft hast und schön, dass Christian Bernhard neben mir sitzt.
Servus Christian. Hallo, schönen guten Morgen.
Ihr seid die verlässlichen Säulen der Ligatur. Ich sag's wie es ist, die Serie A immer mit dabei, La Liga immer mit dabei. Wir wissen aktuell noch nicht, ob wir auch Premier League hinbekommen. Ligue 1 hat schon dankend abgewunken, die haben leider alle Terminprobleme. Premier League, ich weiß es noch nicht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ist es am Ende der Saison bei euch auch so hart stressig? Geht das nur mir so, dass es gerade so viel ist?
Es blättschert bei uns gerade so aus, die La Liga ist ja eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger seit Wochen im Großteil entschieden. Dass wir jetzt noch zwei Spieltage haben, ist eigentlich völlig drüber. Braucht kein Mensch. Ach nee, Moment. Jetzt gehen die Playoffs los in Spanien, was die unteren Ligen anbelangt. Da kommt jetzt noch mal ein bisschen Spannung auf. Aber eigentlich ist alles schon im Hinblick auf diese Playoffs und Relegationsspiele ausgerichtet. Aber alle müssen noch zwei normale Spieltage hinlegen. Die sind eigentlich schon fast überflüssig. Aber gut, es ist so ein bisschen die Lauer-Stellung vor dem großen Saison-Final.
Okay, also ich sehe schon, bei dir ist das Entspannungslevel ein bisschen höher. Wie ist es bei dir, Christian?
Ja, es sind auch einige Entscheidungen schon gefallen. Was in Italien aber schon noch dazukommt, sind ja noch zwei europäische Finals, die anstehen mit Atalanta und Fiorentina. Da kommen wir ja auch noch darauf. Und ja, das muss ich dir ja nicht sagen, Max, die M rückt ja auch immer näher. Also es wird eine relativ kurze Pause nach dem Final. Die Saisonfinale geht dann mehr oder weniger nahtlos weiter.
Ey, ich kriege jetzt schon Stressbrust hin, wenn ich nur daran denke, dass ich parallel zum Rasenfunk Royale eigentlich schon die EM vorbereiten müsste. Aber das soll nicht euer Problem sein, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber es soll erklären, warum wir es jetzt nicht immer geschafft haben, vier Ligen hier abzubilden in den letzten Wochen. Denn der Stress verteilt sich bei vielen dann doch am Saisonende. Nicht jeder hat da die komfortable Situation in La Liga. Aber Fabian, nicht alles ist ja schon komplett entschieden. Also klar, Meisterschaft, worüber reden wir eigentlich, wissen eigentlich schon alle. Und eigentlich dachte man auch, Abstiegskampf im Grunde auch durch. Wir haben da so ein bisschen eine Parallele, so wie jetzt beim ersten FC Köln in der Bundesliga, dass man rein rechnerisch noch die Möglichkeit hatte. Aber es ist quasi nur die Frage, wann steigen sie denn ab? Das war Cadiz. Aber jetzt sehen wir, stand jetzt noch nicht. Und rein theoretisch kann man da noch drinbleiben, weil jetzt zwei Siege in den letzten beiden Spielen. Und deswegen könnte es da unten wirklich noch mal eng werden.
Es könnte tatsächlich noch mal eng werden. Es ist natürlich schon so, dass Cadiz nach wie vor die, ja, schwierigste Ausgangslage hat. Du hast es angesprochen, sie müssen beide Spiele gewinnen und haben dann eventuell noch Chancen. Kurios ist allerdings, dass gleich nächste Woche das Spiel gegen Las Palmas ansteht. Die haben wir ja öfter schon in der Liga-Tour gelobt. Die sind jetzt aber dann doch abgeflaggert bis hier in den letzten Wochen und stehen jetzt plötzlich dort unten drin als Tabellensechzehnte von 20. Und sind nur fünf Punkte vor Cadiz. Ausgerechnet Cadiz und Las Palmas treffen sich nächstes Wochenende in Cadiz. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass Cadiz dieses Spiel gewinnt mit aller Macht, mit allen Fans im Rücken, mit allem, was dazugehört. Dann könnte es tatsächlich noch einen sehr interessanten letzten Spieltag geben.
Was ist denn dabei in Las Palmas los? Ich sehe unter anderem in den letzten sechs Spielen sechs Niederlagen. Sie liest sich nicht so gut.
Ich glaube, da ist die Spannung so ein bisschen abgefallen und leider schon ein bisschen zu früh. Es war halt leider nicht mehr viel zu holen, weder nach oben noch nach unten. Und dann hast du ja schon als Aufsteiger natürlich von der Kaderbreite und so weiter oder von der Kaderqualität allgemein nicht das beste Level. Und ja, da ist natürlich ein bisschen was dann eingebrochen. Vielleicht haben auch viele Spieler überperformt am Anfang der Saison, in der Mitte der Saison noch. Und jetzt ging es so ein bisschen nach unten. Und es waren natürlich auch teilweise Gegner dabei, für die ging es noch um was. Ja, und so ist das dann irgendwie relativ blöd gelaufen für Las Palmas. Oder auch für Mallorca, den Pokalfinalisten, den man auch schon sicher drin gewähnt hatte und der jetzt aber auch nur vier Punkte vor dem FC Cadiz steht auf Platz 17. Nichtsdestotrotz, Max, gehe ich aber davon aus, dass es bei der aktuellen Situation so bleiben wird, dass es Cadiz nicht packen wird. Und gemeinsam mit Granada und Almeria ausgerechnet drei analysische Vereine runtergehen, was mich hier besonders hart trifft, weil ich komme ja hier aus der Region, oder ich komme hier nicht hier, aber ich wohne in dieser Region. Und ja, ist natürlich schade, umso weniger Erstligisten wir haben, umso schlechter ist das natürlich für die Region an sich. Aber es sieht für mich verdächtig danach aus, denn auch das Restprogramm der anderen erlaubt zumindest den meisten noch mindestens ein Spiel sicher zu gewinnen, beziehungsweise hier noch und da ein Unentschieden einzufahren. Also die Vorteile liegen schon noch klar bei den anderen Teams.
Ja, also ich meine, Mallorca könnte es schon am nächsten Spieltag machen. Man spielt gegen den abgeschlagenen letzten Almeria. Über die haben wir ja auch mal kurz irgendwann gesprochen vor ein paar Wochen, als ich schon so abgezeichnet habe. Das läuft gerade nicht so berauschend bei denen. Wenn man das Ergebnis von Cadiz matcht, also eben wenn die gewinnen, sollte man auch gewinnen, wenn die unentschädigen Spiele reichen, unentschieden, blablabla, dann wäre man drin. Mit einem Sieg ist es absolut sicher, weil dann kann man auf jeden Fall die vier Punkte Vorsprung halten. Aber was du dazu Las Palmas erzählt hast, das finde ich schon interessant, weil Cadiz hat halt schon ein interessantes weiteres Programm. Jetzt eben dieser Heimspiel gegen Las Palmas. Klar, man ist in der Situation, man muss dieses Spiel gewinnen, alles andere hilft nicht. Unentschieden wäre schon Abstieg so gut wie sicher. Aber danach spielt ja auch noch Cadiz gegen den Tabellenletzten. Und Las Palmas zu Hause gegen Alaves. Für die geht es jetzt auch um nichts mehr. Aber so schlecht, wie die aktuell in Form sind, die sind ja im Sinkflug eigentlich.
Die sind im Sinkflug, ja. Aber du hast recht, das habe ich mir heute Morgen noch mal angeguckt. Letzter Spieltag zu Hause gegen Alaves, die ihre Hausaufgaben auch schon lange erledigt haben. Über die haben wir ja auch schon mal gesprochen vor ein paar Monaten oder Wochen. Da gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus, dass auch Las Palmas noch mal alle Kräfte motiviert, um da noch mal den letzten Punkt zu holen oder vielleicht den letzten Sieg, je nachdem, wie das Spiel dann auch gegen Cadiz ausgeht. Von daher haben sie es ja noch in der eigenen Hand. Jede Mannschaft, bis auf Cadiz natürlich. Na ja, schauen wir mal, was passiert. Aber wie gesagt, die Vorzeichen stehen schon eher deutlich für den Abstieg des FC Cadiz.
Ist denn das ein Problem für die Liga, dass jetzt im Grunde alle wichtigen Entscheidungen schon getroffen sind? Meisterschaft, Champions League, Europapokal, kann jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr so wirklich. Es kann noch theoretisch was passieren, aber es sieht alles relativ gefestigt aus.
Also ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass sich hier keiner mehr so wirklich für die Liga interessiert. Also natürlich schon interessiert, aber halt die große Spannung ist schon seit ein paar Wochen raus. Es ist jetzt alles auf das Champions League-Finale hier fokussiert. Du weißt ja, Real Madrid ist ja nicht nur ein Stadtverein, sondern ein Landverein. Also dementsprechend ist das das Monothema eigentlich mehr oder weniger. Gut, Barcelona ist immer mal für eine Slapstick-Aussage gut, vor allen Dingen Fener Xavi haut immer mal wieder einen raus und man sich denkt, opa la. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, nachdem Barcelona gegen Girona verloren hat, hat er dann wieder mal eine legendäre Pressekonferenz gegeben, auf dem er gesagt hat, Fußball sei total ungerecht. Sie waren beide in beiden Spielen gegen Girona besser und haben völlig zu Unrecht verloren. Randnotiz, sie haben beide Spiele nämlich verloren und haben dabei acht Tore kassiert. Aber laut Xavi waren sie die bessere Mannschaft. Gegen Madrid wären sie auch besser gewesen, obwohl sie beide Spiele verloren haben. Also, ja, genau. Der FC Barcelona hat seine eigene Geschichte geschrieben.
Das heißt, wenn klar ist, dass er bleibt, ist er völlig entspannt und ist nicht mehr in dem Rage-Modus, den er vorher hatte.
Da brennt es nach wie vor beim FC Barcelona. Also da ist alles andere als Ruhe. Jetzt gibt es die Geschichte noch mit Vitor Roque, den Brasilianer, den sie sich gekauft haben, im Winter für viel Geld, den aber jetzt keiner mehr haben möchte, der wohl im Training so versagt, dass sogar die Spieler gesagt haben, Jungs, was habt ihr denn da gekauft? Und dem wollen sie jetzt irgendwie wieder loswerden ganz schnell.
Händen-Donne.
Ja, eine kuriose Geschichte. Hatte ein paar Kurzeinsätze, hat ein paar hundertprozentige vergeben. Vielleicht hat es auch nicht gerade dazu beigetragen, dass er da großes Vertrauen erntet. Und sie haben, glaube ich, 30 Millionen Ficks damals gezahlt. Ich weiß gar nicht, welcher brasilianische Club das war, wo er herkam. Plus 31 Millionen Variablen, die jetzt am Ende der Saison fällig werden. Also Basa hat wieder mal schön Geld rausgehauen.
Die werden aber auch fällig. Also das sind jetzt nicht Variablen.
Die werden fällig, ja.
Das heißt, sie haben 60 Millionen.
Also das ist Barcelona, das ist Wirtschaft und Transferpolitik in den letzten fünf Jahren. Da könnte der Herr Troika auch ein Buch drüber schreiben.
Ja, soll er mal machen, weil A, ich checke es nicht mehr und B, ist das wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. Weil man nicht wie emotionell...
Also wie viel Geld man verbrennen kann in so kurzer Zeit und vor allem Geld, das man eigentlich nicht hat. Denn Barcelona hat ja noch mehrere hundert Millionen Euro Schulden eigentlich.
Das ist wie so ein Krypto-Scan einfach. Oder so ein NFT-Ding.
Oder so ein Fußballmanager, wo du einfach unendlich ausgeben kannst.
Von Atletico PR kam er. Also ich sehe schon, über Barca wird man mal wieder sprechen können. Aber ja, interessant zu sehen, dass so viel nicht mehr passiert in der Liga. Auch ganz gut, finde ich, ist ein ganz guter Realitätscheck. Denn so gerne, auch ich manchmal über die Bundesliga schimpfe, in den letzten Jahren ging es immer noch was an den letzten Spieltagen. Letzte Saison gab es einen Spieltag, wo alle neun Spiele noch eine Implikation für die Tabelle hatten. Und in dieser Woche sind es, glaube ich, acht von neun Spielen, die wichtig sind. Irgendwie nur Dortmund gegen Darmstadt oder irgendwie so was in der Art ist.
Ich denke mal, Bundesliga ist dieses Jahr deutlich interessanter als die spanische Liga gewesen, würde ich sagen. Weil ich jetzt nicht weiß, ob ich das jetzt so objektiv sagen kann, aber das behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal. Und wenn wir die internationalen Ergebnisse anschauen, dann hatten wir auch gesehen, dass die Liga nicht so performt hat dieses Jahr. Und die Bundesliga überraschend gut und das kann man schon so feststellen, denke ich.
Ja, vor allem, wie die Bundesligisten, die anderen Top-Teams an die Wand gespielt haben in der K.o.-Runde, das war, da werden wir noch in Jahrzehnten von sprechen, liebe Leute. will es ja gar nicht kleinreden, aber ich finde es halt so lustig, wenn deutsche Teams ausscheiden, dann ist hier immer Weltuntergangsstimmung, gerade natürlich, wenn der FC Bayern ausscheidet, und so Themen wie naja, vielleicht hatten sie auch mal ein bisschen Pech. Das darf man da nicht sagen, nein, sie waren dann total schlecht. Sie hätten gegen Villarreal unbedingt gewinnen müssen oder gegen Pégé, wo sie mal mit irgendwie 3,8 x G zu 0,7 in zwei Spielen halt ausgeschieden sind. Da hieß es dann, nein, alles ist schlecht, der Trainer muss weg. Und wenn man dann aber so weiterkommt, dann heißt es, boah, wir sind die geilste Liga überhaupt, ey, schaut euch an, wir hätten fast wieder deutsche Swembley gehabt. Naja, aber gut, das ist nur, ich versuche nur den Gegenpol zu setzen. Also das ist die Situation im Abstiegskampf. Wir wissen genau, welches Spiel wir uns angucken, nämlich Cadiz gegen Las Palmas jetzt am nächsten Wochenende und dann wissen wir, ob sich auch ein Blick aufs übernächste Wochenende noch lohnt. In der Serie A ist es ja noch ein bisschen interessanter, aber auch wegen Europa unter anderem. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, mit welchem Thema du loslegen möchtest, Christian.
Ja, ganz klar mit der Aktualität. Denn so wie bei Fabian, wo ja am Mittwoch gespielt wurde in der Liga, wurde in Italien am Mittwochabend auch gespielt. Zwar nicht in der Liga, aber das Coppa Italia hat ja in Rom stattgefunden. Juve gegen Atalanta. Juve hat es gewonnen mit 1 zu 0. Und deswegen würde ich als erstes... Ja, genau, richtig. Der musste kommen. Deswegen würde ich anfangen mit Juve. Erstmal zum Spiel. Wlauowicz in der 4. Minute. Schon sehr früh das 1 zu 0. Das hat dann standgehalten. Juve hatte in den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten zu Recht mehr als genug Kritik geerntet. Ich habe es nur nochmal angeschaut. Das ist schon beeindruckend, die Zahlen. Juve war Anfang Freiburg noch punktegleich mit Inter. Sie waren wirklich im Meisterrennen. Dann gab es das 1 zu 1 gegen Empoli, die Woche vor, Inter und dann die Niederlage in San Siro. Da wurde im Prinzip das Stecker gezogen. Das hat man bei den Spielern immer wieder gehört. Die haben wirklich daran geglaubt, an Inter dran bleiben zu können. Aber ab da war diese Glaube weg. Fabian hat es gerade so schön gesagt. Spannungsabfall. Den konnte man bei Juve dann auch deutlich feststellen. Juve hat in den 14 Spielen seither in der Liga 14 Punkte geholt. Weniger als Abstiegskandidaten. Empoli zum Beispiel, im Moment noch 18 auf dem Abstiegsplatz, hat mehr Punkte geholt als Juve in dieser Zeit. Und Juve ist im Prinzip jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende in die Champions League gestolpert. Sie hatten ja dieses riesige Polster, wo eigentlich jeder dachte, ja gut, das Ding ist durch. Aber eben durch diese Negativ-Serie wurde es echt nochmal relativ eng. Und jetzt am Wochenende haben sie durch ein glorioses 1 zu 1 zu Hause gegen die Salernitana, die schon seit Wochen abgestiegen ist, Ausgleich in der 91. Das hat dann gereicht, weil dann am Abend Atalanta die Roma geschlagen hat. Und seitdem war klar, okay, Juve hat jetzt diesen Platz 4 sicher, Platz 5 reicht in Italien auch dieses Jahr, weil ja die europäischen Spiele so gut waren. Und dementsprechend war jetzt der volle Fokus, logisch, seit Wochen auf dieses Pokalfinale. Und die Frage war wirklich, können sie Atalanta Paroli bieten? Denn das, was Atalanta in den letzten Wochen geleistet hat, und darauf kommen wir später auch noch, war wirklich beeindruckend. Und ich muss echt sagen, ich durfte das Spiel gestern mit kommentieren, und es war beeindruckend, was Juve da geleistet hat. Denn es war eben wirklich nicht nur dieses, jetzt kann man sagen, okay, denken sich viele, ja gut, Juve macht das Tor und dann verteidigen das irgendwie über die Runden. Es war deutlich mehr. Also Juve hat von Anfang an, sie waren mutig am Anfang, das hatten sie auch ein paar Mal in der Saison in den großen Spielen, dass sie so phasenweise versucht haben, Intensität hochzuhalten, auch hoch anzulaufen, einfach mit Energie rein zu starten. Gestern wurden sie früh belohnt. Tolles Tor von Blauowitsch, der da, der einen kleinen Lücke hatte, weil eben, kann man auch später nochmal drauf zu sprechen, Atalanta dieses nach vorne verteidigen, da entsteht halt manchmal, wenn das Timing nicht genau passt, entsteht etwas Platz. Und da hat Blauowitsch den Wunderball genutzt, den Ball super abgeschirmt, dann im 1 gegen 1 gegen Karnesecki mit seinem schwachen rechten Klasse abgeschlossen. Und Juve ist dann aber drangeblieben. Also Juve hat die Intensität hochgehalten, hat kurz danach fast das 2-0 nachgelegt und hat dann wirklich, und das wirklich, das meine ich mit in positiver Art, in bester Juve-DNA-Manier, Allegri-Manier dieses Spiel dann verteidigt, aber eben mit hoher Intensität und hoher Konzentration am Ende. Und das finde ich wirklich die größte Leistung. Atalanta hatte keinen einzigen Schuss nach 97 Minuten aufs Juvetor. Also sie haben wirklich all das gezeigt, was Allegri eigentlich jetzt im Prinzip im positiven in dieser seiner zweiten Juve-Zeit ausmacht. Das, was wir in der Hinrunde gesehen haben, warum Juve eben so lange an Inter drangeblieben war, also wirklich höchste Defensivgier und Konzentration, denn wenn du so wie Juve verteidigst, nämlich oft sehr tiefstehend und dir den Gegner wirklich regelmäßig an den eigenen Strafraum oder in den eigenen Strafraum reinholst, dann brauchst du halt auch diesen defensiven Fokus. Du darfst dir keine Fehler leisten. Da müssen die Abstellende passen, und das muss aber auch die Konzentration passen. Das war in der Rückrunde alles wie weggewischt. Die haben Tore kassiert, hier, da, dort. Und gestern war das halt alles wieder da. Sie haben es jetzt noch einmal gebraucht in dieser Saison. Und da haben sie es abgerufen. Sie hatten in der zweiten Hälfte auch noch ein, zwei wirklich gefährliche Konter. Am Ende waren Lattenknaller noch von Marete dabei. Also es war wirklich ein sehr, sehr verdienter, knapper 1 zu 0-Sieg. Und wie gesagt, diese Max Allegri Juve DNA in all ihrer, ja, sag ich mal, in all ihrer Potenzialen. Ja, Juwehaftigkeit.
Aber was heißt das jetzt? Heißt das, diese Frage muss ich auch so formulieren, dazu bin ich gezwungen. Heißt das, er hat die Kabine noch nicht verloren?
Schöne Frage, ja. Jetzt kommen wir endlich zu Herrn Allegri, denn da gab es ja gestern auch einige Szenen. Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, schaut es euch an. Allegri ist kurz vor Schluss, er ist vom Platz geflogen, er ist mehr oder weniger, er hat fast ein komplettes Striptease an der Seitenlinie abgeliefert. Vielleicht erinnern sich ein paar, es gibt immer wieder so eine Allegri-Szene kurz vor Schluss, wo er sehr intensiv wird, wo irgendwie die Emotionen raus müssen. Und gestern, glaube ich, hat sich das, was sich jetzt über Wochen und Monate angestaut hat, das war eigentlich gar keine extreme Szene der Auslöser, sondern ich glaube, das war wirklich all das, was jetzt über Wochen und Monate da war. Und er ist vom Platz geflogen, hat sich da noch fast, ich dachte kurz, er zieht sich auch noch das Hemd aus, also hat sich das Jackett ausgezogen, die Krawatte ausgezogen. Und da hast du halt gemerkt, hat sich alles entladen, weil er, und da ist ja der spannende Punkt jetzt, deswegen wollte ich unbedingt das Juve-Thema mitbringen, es deutet jetzt schon sehr vieles darauf hin, dass das einfach der Abschluss war bei Mitteilege und Juve. Er hat zwar noch ein Jahr Vertrag, aber die Vorzeichen, vieles deutet in die Richtung, dass das jetzt eben der Abschluss war. Auch gestern gab es ein paar Szenen, er saß dann am Ende, als die Mannschaft unter der Kurve war, mit seinem ganzen Trainerteam auf einer Werbebande. Er hat das Ganze so lächelnd beobachtet. Es gab auch ein paar Aussagen nach dem Spiel, wo er irgendwann einen Interview gefragt hat, wie sie mich schon entlassen haben. Auch so einen ironischen Unterton. Er hat ein paar Mal auch Sätze fallen lassen, wie, falls es zu Ende sein sollte, dahinter lasse ich eine gute Mannschaft. Ich finde, es deutet jetzt schon vieles darauf hin. Er hat auch gemeint, der Klub ist derjenige, der entscheidet, mit welchem Trainer es weitergeht. Ich glaube, das war das letzte große Spiel von Allegri mit Juve. Dementsprechend war es für ihn auch extrem wichtig. Es ist jetzt sein drittes Jahr bei Juve. Es war bis jetzt titellos. Das war ja immer die Prämisse, die er hatte. Er hat gemeint, Allegri steht wie kein anderer für diesen Ergebnisfußball und für Aussagen wie, es ist egal, wie man spielt, man muss erfolgreich spielen. Das war er in den zwei Jahren nicht. Aber jetzt hat er zumindest am Ende diesen einen Titel eingetütet. Er hat die Champions League-Quality dieses Jahr eingetütet. Das war das große Ziel. Im Prinzip hat er die zwei Ziele erreicht. Er hatte ja keinen anderen Pokalwettbewerb. Das war er der Einzige in der Saison, den er gewinnen konnte. Ich glaube, jetzt ist es wirklich auch Zeit für etwas Neues. Dementsprechend war das so emotional aufgeladen. Von seiner Seite, auch von Spielers Seite, die waren wirklich scharfgestellt von Sekunde eins und haben abgeliefert. Ich glaube, jetzt kann dann im Sommer auch ein neues Kapitel beginnen.
Jetzt muss ich natürlich fragen, sollte Xavi Alonso mit Allegri telefonieren?
Ich bin mir sicher, dass er sich das sehr genau angeschaut hat. Deswegen, ich spoilere mir schon mal, oder Max? Wir kommen im zweiten Teil an zu Atalanta, weil es passt jetzt wunderbar auch Richtung kommende Woche zum Finale. Aber man kann ja zum Juvestil stehen, wie man will. Deswegen ist das ja auch Teil dieser Geschichte zu Allegri. Ich finde ja auch, dass es wirklich Zeit für einen frischen Input bei Juve ist. Man kann Allegri auch in dieser Saison einiges vorwerfen. Zu Recht diese spielerische Weiterentwicklung gab es nicht. Wir hatten mal eine Folge im Januar, Max, du erinnerst dich, wo ich dachte, da ist es mal wochenlang aufgeplitzt, da kommt diese spielerische Weiterentwicklung. Nein, das war wirklich nur ein kurzes Strohfeuer. Also es gibt genügend Gründe, sozusagen dieses Kapitel jetzt einfach, Allegri bis, also die 2. Allegri Regentschaft bei Juve, jetzt definitiv schon mit einem Jahr früher abzuschließen. Aber in dem gestrigen Spiel, das war halt ein Finale, und da war Juve so eingestellt, wie du gegen Atalanta spielen musst. Und wirklich von Minute 1 bis 97. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass sie in Rhythmus mitgehen können. Ich habe nur darauf gewartet, dass sie irgendwann abfallen, weil das ist ja die Gefahr, wenn du so spielst wie Allegri, wenn du dir den Gegner immer ranholst und du wirst müde. Das hinten raus und der Gegner ist dauernd, es kommen die zweiten Perle, hohe Ballgewinne und dann rollt eine Welle nach der anderen. Ich mich hätte nicht überrascht, wenn sie die Konzentration nicht hochgehalten hätten. Aber was Bremer, Danilo und Gatti da hinten im Zentrum wegverteidigt haben, wie eng die Abstände auch noch in der 90. waren, wie sie die Lücken geschlossen haben, das war, muss man sagen, beeindruckend. Und das war halt genau das, was sie gestern gebraucht haben.
Spricht Maximilian Allegri, spricht er Deutsch oder Englisch?
Er hat noch ein Jahr Vertrag. Max Allegri verdient bei Juve angeblich 7 Millionen Netto. Da sprechen wir also von 14 Millionen brutto. Also da geht es jetzt auch darum, wenn das so kommen sollte, logisch eine Lösung zu finden. Wird der Vertrag aufgelöst? Gibt es eine Abfindung? Also da ist schon noch einiges, was zu klären ist. Nochmal, es ist ja auch noch nicht offiziell. Also aber es deutet vieles darauf hin, dass Cristiano Junto lebend, der Sportdirektor, der im vergangenen Sommer von Napoli kam und der wirklich die Macht jetzt bei Juve hat, die auch von John Elkan, vom Präsidenten offiziell übertragen bekommen hat. Das auch klar war jetzt auch, egal wie dieses Finale ausgeht, ich glaube, diese Entscheidung ist eigentlich intern schon gefallen. Jetzt geht es darum, wie kommuniziert man die? Und dann ist die Frage, ob man Thiago Mota bekommt. Das ist das große Ziel, die große Hoffnung bei Juve. Und ich sage mal so, wenn es wirklich so kommen sollte, wenn sie es schaffen, Thiago Mota zu überzeugen, Allegrette ist völlig zurecht gestern gesagt, ich hinterlasse etwas oder ich würde etwas potenziell hinterlassen, mit dem man sehr gut arbeiten kann. Und wenn ich nur daran denke, wenn Thiago Mota mit Yildiz und Cambiasos und einigen der jungen Fadjoli kommt nach Sperre zurück, dazu noch die ganzen Chiesas und Bremas und so, da ist schon Potenzial da. Ich muss sagen, ich würde mich auch freuen, da wirklich mal das neue Juve-Projekt zu sehen, mit so einem womöglich so spannenden Trainer wie Thiago Mota. Aber gestern Abend, das war halt erstmal noch mal der Abend von Max Allegrette, der hier Alden nochmal, und das darf man nicht vergessen, in den letzten Tagen war auch in Italien Atalanta der Favorit in diesem Spiel. Denn Atalanta hat einfach, was sie gezeigt haben in den Wochen davor und was Juve gezeigt hat. Also die sportlichen Voraussetzungen waren klar Richtung Atalanta, aber Juve war halt on point da und hat das nochmal in bester Juve-Manier mit Silberware beendet, diese Saison.
Aber würde jetzt Thiago Mota von Bologna, die in die Champions League geführt hat, zu Juve wechseln, was würde Susi Hoeneß über ihn sagen? Und über seinen Charakter? Könnte er danach noch Bayern-Trainer werden? Deswegen, er darf das nicht tun.
Muss er am Tegernsee noch kurz vorbeischauen oder so.
Ich agitiere schon seit Wochen für Thiago Mota, aber das will hier irgendwie keiner hören.
Also, Thiago Mota hat logisch einige Optionen und vielleicht macht er am Ende den Xabi Alonso und bleibt auch wirklich noch und macht es mit Bologna. Es ist schwer vorstellbar, oder was heißt, es ist noch nichts da. Bei Bologna wird logisch alles probiert, um ihn logischerweise zum Darbleiben zu überzeugen. Juve wird auch alles probieren, andere auch. Also, ich würde mal sagen, seit Xabi Alonso ja vom Markt ist, seit er sich selbst vom Markt genommen hat, ist Thiago Mota mittlerweile, würde ich sagen, mit die heißeste Traineraktie. Und wenn es Juve wirklich gelingen sollte, dann würde ich sagen, dann kann da echt endlich dieses Neue noch mal, auch wenn der Legi das jetzt mit dem Pokal beendet hat, es ist höchste Zeit bei Juve, dass da frischer Wind reinkommt. Und am Ende war es jetzt vielleicht das erfolgreiche Ende, ein Abschied, ein emotionaler Abschied. Und ja, also ich würde es Juve wünschen, wenn das mit Thiago Mota klappen sollte.
Was ist eigentlich mit de Serbi, den alle wollen, aber keiner nimmt ihn? Und bleibt er jetzt doch bei Brighton oder wird er in Italien mit Teams in Verbindung gebracht, was er vielleicht auf der Hand legen würde?
Ja, in Italien ist der Name bei Milan auch immer wieder mal gefallen, gar keine Frage. Aber in Italien, was schon ein Riesenhindernis ist, er hatte angeblich eine Ausstiegsklausel von 14 Millionen. Und das ist für italienische Verhältnisse schon massiv.
Der ist ja billiger als Oliver Glasner.
Ja, bei Milan war er jetzt immer wieder mal auch noch in der Verlosung, aber ich glaube, Italien ist im Moment, ich glaube auch nicht, dass er jetzt schon zurückkommt. Der wird irgendwann, er kommt zum Beispiel auch in der Milan-Jugend, aber ich glaube schon, dass er entweder erst mal noch Premier League weiter oder, wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch mal einen Anruf aus München. Keine Ahnung, was da noch alles passiert oder nicht passiert.
Nur wenn Max Eber seinen Willen bekäme, aber da ist er zum falschen Verein. Wenn der Alte vom Tigersee nicht nickt.
Genau, aber der Tserbi ist im Moment, also es ist wirklich, das wäre ein eigenes Thema, vielleicht nach der Saison. Bis auf Inter, mit den Sargi, wo alles fix ist. Und Gasperini, der ja auch womöglich Napoli baggert dran. Aber ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen, dass Gasperini bei Atalanta bleibt. Alle anderen großen wechseln oder haben gewechselt. Roma und Lazio erst vor wenigen Wochen. Bei Juve, womöglich bei Milan, womöglich bei Napoli wird alles neu. Also es wird wirklich ein sehr spannender Trainersommer auch in Italien.
Aber wirklich, wir haben ja hier so viele Trainergeschichten in Deutschland. Aber ganz kurz zu dieser Oliver Glasner, Crystal Palace Nummer. Ich finde, das ist so eine verloren gegangene Anekdote, weil gerade so viele andere Sachen passieren und weil es natürlich nicht gut überliefert ist. Aber ist es nicht lustig, dass Crystal Palace, wenn alles so stimmt und sie eben quasi einfach 100 Millionen Euro gefordert haben vor dem Glasner, dass sie dann quasi das Uli Hoeneß-Ribéry-Ding durchgezogen haben? Uli Hoeneß ist doch eine seiner Lieblingsanedote, dass Florentino Perez von Real Madrid anruft und Ribéry in seiner Prime kaufen will. Das ist kein Problem, nimm einen Zettel vor dich, da schreibst du jetzt eine 1 drauf, dann eine 0 und noch eine 0 und dann häckst du noch 6 0 dran und vorher reden wir überhaupt gar nicht. Und dann hat der Perez sich nie mehr gemeldet. Und ich fände es so lustig, wenn Christian das ganz genau so gemacht hat. Ja, Oliver Glasner könnte das schon haben. Also nehmt doch mal einen Zettel. Nehmt doch mal eine 1. Na gut, aber vielleicht bin ich da jetzt auch gehässig.
Dass ein Team wie Crystal Palace dann auch solche Anforderungen stellen kann. Oder beziehungsweise sagen kann, nö, brauchen wir nicht. Man muss ja echt sagen, dass Crystal Palace eine Wahnsinns-Rückrunde spielt.
Ich meine, genau, aber, also Punkt 1, alles nur Gerüchte. Und wir erliegen dann natürlich dem Transferjournalismus. Keine Ahnung, ob es genau so war. Aber Punkt 2, wenn es so war und Oli Glasner wirklich angefragt wurde von Bayern, wie random willst du denn deine Trainer aussuchen? Also ist jetzt Spiel-Idee wirklich scheißegal? Und ich will damit überhaupt nichts gegen Oli Glasner sagen, der ein total netter Typ ist, glaube ich. Aber das würde doch, also wirklich, könnt ihr euch bitte mal überlegen, welchen Fußball ihr spielen wollt und dann einen Trainer holen? Aber wirklich dieses, also dann kann auch ich das Trainer-Scouting machen, weil dann gucke ich nämlich auch einfach nur, wer verfügbar ist. Also Entschuldigung, da könnte ich mich unendlich drüber aufregen. Und dass da auch alle so kommentarlos mitmachen, so ja klar haben sie jetzt Rangnick angefragt. Ja, Moment mal, sie wollten doch vorher einen ganz anderen Trainer haben. Es ist überhaupt nicht klar, dass sie jetzt Rangnick angefragt haben.
Aber schön, wie wir von Allegri zu Oli Glasner gekommen sind. Da haben wir eine interessante Abbiegung genommen.
Da sind wir den Kurzen Weg gegangen.
Einmal über die Alpen drüber, oder?
Dabei hatte ich ja schon, ich hatte mir die Überleitung schon überlegt, weil wir waren ja auch kurz bei Bologna. Und Bologna darf ja in der Champions League antreten. Nächstes Jahr überraschend. In La Liga haben wir Girona und da ist das nicht so klar. Und das, obwohl man sich sportlich qualifiziert hat.
Ja, es ist kurios bei Girona, wie vielleicht einige der Zuhörer schon wissen, ist Girona gehört zu einem Teil der Man City Group, und zwar zu einem angeblichen Prozentteil von 47%. Und jetzt kam die UEFA und hat gesagt, Moment, wenn ihr nächstes Jahr Champions League spielen wollt, dann dürft ihr von der Man City Group eine maximale Anteilnahme von nur 30% haben. Weil Man City folgerichtig natürlich auch in der Champions League steht. Jetzt ist es tatsächlich so, dass Girona versuchen muss, in kürzester Zeit diese 17% oder von denen zumindest geschrieben wird, loszuwerden. Und damit sie nächstes Jahr Champions League spielen dürfen. Sie sind da auch sehr positiv eingestimmt, dass das gelingt. Ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass sich da jemand finden lässt, der das Paket einfach mal mitnimmt. Dann gibt es ja noch irgendwo einen Cousin oder irgendein Fond. Irgendetwas wird sich schon finden lassen. Aber es ist kurios, die Uefa hat auf jeden Fall Girona gewarnt. Jungs, ihr müsst es unter Kontrolle kriegen, sonst dürft ihr nächstes Jahr nicht Champions League spielen. Und da musste ich ganz kurz an die Geschichte denken mit Red Bull oder mit Raba Leipzig und Red Bull Salzburg. Wie war denn da die Geschichte? Ich habe die nämlich nicht genau auf dem Schirm.
Na, die mussten nachweisen, dass sie zwei unabhängig voneinander agierende Vereine sind, also Vereine natürlich so ein bisschen ein Anführungszeichen, bei denen quasi nicht der Sponsor die Vorgaben macht. Und dass sie quasi, und dass quasi die, es gab ja damals schon eine Doppelfunktion. Ich glaube, war das nicht sogar noch Alf Ranglick, der quasi für alle der sportliche Leiter war. Und das mussten sie dann zum Beispiel voneinander entkoppeln, weil sonst hätte eben eine Einflussnahme stattfinden können. Und dann haben sie das natürlich lückenlos nachweisen können, weil diese beiden Teams haben ja nichts miteinander zu tun. Und dann hat die Uefa draufgeschaut und hat gesagt, ja, jetzt ist alles super.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer bei Girona genau die Fäden im Hintergrund zieht. Mit 47 Prozent Anteil an einem Club kannst du natürlich schon, hast du natürlich schon ein gutes Wort. Das ist auf jeden Fall mal Fakt. Und es ist ja auch so, dass man sich Spieler gerne hin und her schiebt, verleiht und so weiter.
Ist das nicht genau das Ding? Also wenn wir uns jetzt darauf einlassen, darüber zu diskutieren, ab wie viel Prozent ist das jetzt zulässig oder nicht, das ist doch eigentlich, glaube ich, schon die falsche Argumentation. Also das mag jetzt so ein juristisches Ding sein, und Uefa sichert sich ab und vielleicht wird die Uefa auch ein Signal senden, weil Multiclub-Ownership ein wichtiges Ding wird. Aber auf der anderen Seite, also zum einen in den entsprechenden Uefa-Komitees sitzen inzwischen schon Multiclub-Owners, die entscheiden. Und zum anderen, es wird sich ja nicht an einem Prozentpunkt entscheiden, ob jetzt da die City Holding mitspricht oder nicht, sondern eben in solchen Spielertransfers zeigt sich das. Also, man kann ja auch mal nach Thuac gucken, was da passiert ist in der Liga. Es ist sehr schade, dass wir das zeitlich einfach jetzt wirklich nicht hinbekommen haben, das mal aufzuarbeiten. Das ist ja völlig irre. Die steigen ab, weil der beste Spieler, der geholt wurde, vom Investor direkt zu seinem anderen Club weitergeleitet wurde. Der hat nie eine Minute für Thuac gespielt, aber Thuac musste die Kohle zahlen und geht jetzt runter. Und dann schmeißen die Fans Pyro-Fackeln aufs Feld und Spieler haben die tolle Idee, diese Pyro-Fackeln zurückzuwerfen.
Es ist eine verrückte Konstellation. Ich gehe auch davon aus, nehmen wir mal an, Girona ist Champions League nächstes Jahr. Die haben schon ein paar Spieler, die werden nächstes Jahr nicht mehr bei Girona spielen. Da gibt es einige, die auf den Zetteln der großen Clubs stehen. Dann ist es ja für solche Mannschaften doch eigentlich immer schwierig, adäquaten Ersatz zu finden. Du hast halt schon ein bisschen Geld, aber du bist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie die attraktivste, neueste Mannschaft in der Champions League. Aber gut, da hast du halt wieder den Fundus der Gruppe oder der Holding, die dann noch ein paar Spieler verteilt haben in der Welt. Dann holst du dir vielleicht den Kollegen von Lazio Rum zurück, den Stürmer, die Castellanos. Vielleicht machst du es dann wieder so. Also da wird es im Sommer wieder einige Mauschenlein und Hin und Her verschieben.
Ja, das ist der Punkt. Sind wir mal ehrlich, oder? Also zwei Punkte. Zweifelt jemand von uns daran, dass Girona nächstes Jahr Champions League spielen wird? Nein. Nein. So, überraschenderweise werden diese 17 Prozent irgendwo unterkommen. Vielleicht, weil die Main City Group auch eine gute Idee hat. Also ich finde, das ist halt wieder so ein klassischer Uefa-Move. Die können sich jetzt erst mal da relativ stark hinstellen und sagen, hey, liebe Leute, so geht es ja nicht. Aber es wird so kommen, Girona wird spielen, es wird irgendeine Lösung gefunden werden. Und das, was Fabian gesagt hat, klar werden die ein, zwei verlieren, aber die werden halt im Sommer auch wieder ein, zwei, drei aus diesem Kosmos halt wieder rübergeschoben bekommen. Also im Prinzip ist das für mich so ein klassischer Fall. Da kann sich die Uefa nach außen hin, sage ich mal, relativ stark positionieren. Aber im Prinzip wissen alle Beteiligten, dass es mehr oder weniger genauso weiterlaufen wird und das Grundproblem überhaupt nicht damit angegangen wird.
Und das Grundproblem ist ein großes. Beispiel Yanguel Herrera, da wurde letzte Saison ausgeliehen von Manchester City, spielt in Defensive Mittelfeld, 26 Jahre alt, wurde jetzt fest verpflichtet für eine kolportierte Ablösesumme von 5 Millionen Euro. Ich meine, ja, er ist schon 26. Aber nennen wir mal irgendeinen Spieler von Manchester City, der für 5 Millionen Euro so ist. Aber ja, es wird so kommen und das ganze Multi-Club-Ownishap ist ein Riesenproblem. Und wisst ihr, woran man das unter anderem auch erkennen kann? Daran, dass der FC Bayern sein eigenes Multi-Club-Ownishap-Ding aufmachen wollte. Was sie jetzt wieder einstampfen, nachdem es... Also die Kurve hat natürlich mal wieder dagegen plakatiert. Es gab dann die ersten Medien, die nachgefragt haben, meine Theorie dazu ist, ohne irgendeine Quelle dazu zu haben, dass Uli Hoeneß sich das angeguckt hat und gesagt hat, was soll denn der Scheiß, sowas machen wir nicht. Und dann haben sie es wieder zurückgedreht. Aber Red and Gold, das war genau so ein Ding. Mit dem Grasshopper Zürichs, dann mit dem uruguayanischen Rekordmeister, zusammen mit Los Angeles FC. Deswegen wäre es keine Multiclub-Ownership im engeren Sinne gewesen, weil sie hätten sich 50-50 in der Holding, Red and Gold, und die geht dann in Vereine rein. Dann ist es quasi nicht so, wie wenn du jetzt direkt als Verein, wo ein Hauptsponsor von dir quasi dem Verein gehört und der dann auch in andere reingeht. Aber wenn der FC Bayern sowas macht, der ja sehr gut vernetzt ist, der genau sieht, wie sich der Markt entwickelt, dann ist es ein deutlicher Hinweis darauf, dass diese Triple Sevens dieser Welt, die City Holdings dieser Welt, dass die quasi jetzt den neuen Fußball formen. Sonst würden sie bei sowas nicht mitmachen wollen. Sie drehen es jetzt wieder zurück, nachdem, was ich gehört habe. Alles sehr, man erfährt dazu auffallend wenig, aber wenn jemand vom FC Bayern das hört, ruft mich gerne mal an und beschwert euch, ich hätte mal gerne ein paar mehr Infos, weil auf Presseanfragen gibt es da auch nicht so viel. Aber das ist ein Hinweis darauf, Multiclub ownership ist jetzt das Ding, was sich durchsetzen wird. Und wenn du es nicht so machst wie Triple Seven, nämlich dass du dir quasi zu viele Klubs kaufst und halt gar kein Geld hast, da geht ja gerade alles dahin bei Triple Seven. Da kannst du jede Woche, ich sammle immer so Links für das Tribügenspräch, wo es irgendwann mal kommt. Ich werde es nicht machen können, weil erst, wenn die wahrscheinlich komplett insolvent gegangen sind, kann ich es machen, weil erst dann kann ich sicher sein, dass keine neuen Nachrichten mehr kommen innerhalb der nächsten drei Tage. Das ist einfach der Wahnsinn, was bei Triple Seven passiert. Ja, so wird der neue Fußball sein. Jetzt die Frage, welche Holdings sich mal den ganzen andalusischen Clubs annehmen kann.
Wie gesagt, der FC Malaga ist ja nach wie vor sehr begehrt. Aber er darf oder kann, es kann ja noch keiner einsteigen, weil leider die Justiz immer noch nicht geklärt hat, wie viele Aktienanteile noch Althani gehören, wie viel diese anderen Hotelkette, die noch involviert ist. Solange dieses Thema nicht geklärt ist, kann keiner einsteigen und wir krebsen rum in der dritten Liga. Es ist eine furchtbare Situation seit inzwischen schon vier Jahren. 2020 ging es los mit dem juristisch eingesetzten Geschäftsführer. Es ist ganz traurig, es ist im Moment sportlich auch ganz heiß bei uns. Die Playoffs gehen jetzt los. Malaga hat sich jetzt gerade noch so reingewurstelt. Sie spielen gerade unterirdisch schlecht. Wir wollen jetzt aber irgendwie versuchen aufzusteigen. Aber alle sind sich jetzt einig in den Playoffs. Das werden ganz andere Spiele. Er wird die Mannschaft ganz anders auftreten. Na ja, wir werden sehen. Aber Andalusien ist ein Pflaster, das immer interessant sein wird für Investoren. Die Spanier sind ja schon auch bereit, sich zu gewissen Graden zu öffnen. Wir haben das Beispiel von Almeria gesehen. Ich glaube auch, dass der Saudi-Minister da jetzt nicht aussteigen wird, trotz des Abstiegs. Ganz im Gegenteil, der plant schon wieder eine packenden Mannschaft für die 2. Liga nächstes Jahr. Und in Granada steckt ja, glaube ich, auch ein chinesischer Vortritt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Dem war der Abstieg letztes Jahr auch wurscht. Die sind ja wieder hochgegangen. Die gehen jetzt wieder runter. Die werden aber auch dabei bleiben. Wir haben die Geschichte mit Valencia und Peter Lim. Also, ja, da gibt es schon noch was zu holen, wenn hier wer investieren möchte.
Ja, und um vielleicht die Klammer auch noch zu Italien zu schließen, gerade mit der Man City-Group, also auch mit diesem Multneuropa-Pallermo, das ist ja auch bei denen. Und Pallermo ist jetzt in Italien. Die Serie B fangen jetzt ja auch die Aufstiegs-Playoffs an. Und Pallermo ist in den Aufstiegs-Playoffs. Die sind zwar so als siebter, achter, auch eher so, haben sich eher so reingeben. Oder die letzten Wochen waren alles andere als erfolgreich. Aber rein theoretisch könnten die auch noch dieses Jahr schon aufsteigen. Dann hätte die Man City-Group potenziell schon mal den nächsten Erstligisten in der großen Liga. Also das ist schon ein Thema, finde ich, dass auch wenn es bei Pallermo jetzt dieses Jahr nicht klappen sollte, dann vielleicht nächstes Jahr. Also die Tentakeln sind da schon sehr, sehr weit und sehr breit ausgefahren.
Ja, und wie gesagt...
Noch eine schöne sportliche Nachricht aus Spanien. Deportivo La Coruña ist zurück im Profifußball. Nach vier Jahren 3. Liga sind sie aufgestiegen in die 2. Liga, endlich wieder. Da sieht man mal, wie lang so was dauern kann bei so einem großen Club. Da freue ich mich auch schon um FC Malaga drauf, nächstes Jahr wieder auf die 3. Liga dann quasi. Nein, aber die haben es geschafft. Und die haben auch, glaube ich, ich weiß keine ausländischen Investoren, sondern nur galizische. Da steckt, glaube ich, eine galizische Bank mit dahinter. Aber es ist alles lokal. Und da freue ich mich sehr, dass die es endlich wieder geschafft haben. Die 2. Liga, die haben einen, muss ich euch nicht erzählen, jeder kennt Deportivo La Corunda, die haben eine tolle Fanbase, tolle Stadion. Alles da, um Erstliga-Fußball zu spielen. Und ich hoffe, dass sie auf nächstes Jahr in der 2. Liga dann erfolgreich sein werden.
Das stimmt, ja richtig. Hätte ich jetzt glatt schon wieder vergessen, aber das ging ja ein bisschen rum, dass die aufgestiegen sind in der letzten Woche. Ich hätte noch ganz viele Dinge zu investieren zu sagen, aber das lasse ich mal an der Stelle. Ich meine, alle Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen meine Meinung sowieso dazu. Wir wollen doch ein bisschen in die Aktualität zurück hüpfen. Wir wollen doch mal über Atalanta sprechen und was da ansteht. Und ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher, habe ich das richtig gelesen in einem Artikel, dass Atalanta jetzt mit den Finalspielen, die man hatte, also Coppa Italia ging ja jetzt schon verloren, aber dass das die Chance auf den ersten Titel der Vereinsgeschichte oder Pokaltitel der Vereinsgeschichte wäre, zumindest seit sehr langem.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der erste. Vor 60 Jahren hat Atalanta mal die Coppa Italia gewonnen. Also der steht in der Vitrine, aber der steht halt schon ein paar Jährchen da. Dementsprechend war das gestern die erste Chance, die jetzt erstmal wieder liegen gelassen wurde. Aber der Unterschied, also muss man sagen, der Coppa Italia-Fluch von Gasparini und Atalanta ging weiter. Es war jetzt das dritte Coppa Italia-Finale seit 2019. Sie haben es zum dritten Mal verloren. 2019 gegen Lazio, damals noch mit Insagi, Milinkovic Savic und die Großen. Vor drei Jahren gab es genau auch schon Juve gegen Atalanta. Da war es ein 2-1 relativ knapp. Da hat Chiesa damals auch das entscheidende Tor erzielt. Und gestern war es wirklich so, dass, wie gesagt, Atalanta ist eigentlich als sportlicher Favorit da reingegangen, hat sich aber die Zähne ausgebissen. Aber, und das ist eben das Besondere, und deswegen bietet sich das Thema ja heute an, und das hat man auch im Nachgang gesehen. Also Gianpiero Gasparini, muss ich sagen, ist ja auch einer, der sehr emotional sein kann. Aber gestern hatte er fast schon ein Lächeln nach dem Spiel drauf. Er hat auch nach dem Spiel gemeint, das war okay, wir haben alles probiert, Juve war den Tick besser. Aber eben, und das ist der große Unterschied, in den letzten Jahren war halt dieses Coppa Italia Finale die eine Chance, die sie hatten. Und dieses Jahr aber haben sie noch mal was in der Hinterhand, nämlich kommenden Mittwoch das Europa League Finale gegen Leverkusen. Und Gasperini hat in den vergangenen Wochen auch öffentlich nie einen Hail daraus gemacht, dass das Europa League Finale einfach die 1A-Variante jetzt für sie in dieser Saison ist. Denn, und jetzt kommt, weil du meinst, das erste Mal, Gasperini hat Atalanta zum allerersten Mal in europäisches Finale geführt. Also Atalanta stand noch nie in einem europäischen Finale. Und dementsprechend, glaube ich, lohnt es sich da heute ein bisschen darüber zu sprechen. Ja, gestern, wie gesagt, hat es nicht geklappt. Was zum Teil auch daran lag, dass Skamaka gesperrt gefehlt hat. Und der ging ihnen gestern extrem ab. Skamaka, der Mittelstürmer, der in den vergangenen Wochen gerade in der Europa League, eigentlich, hat ja an der Einfield-Vote bei dem legendären 3-0-Hinspielerfolge im Viertelfinale zwei Buden gemacht, das dritte mit eingeleitet gegen Marseille jetzt, eines der entscheidenden Tore im Rückspiel geschossen, auch in der Liga wirklich wieder in Schwung gekommen. Und der war gestern aufgrund einer Gelbsperre wegen der zweiten gelben Karte. Ach, ja, ja, also diese Regelung wirklich aus dem Mittelalter. Der hat im Rückspiel des Coppa Italia-Halbfinals gegen Florenz die Gelbe gesehen und war dadurch gesperrt im Finale. Also sehr, sehr schade, war auch ein großes Thema. Hat Gasperini auch gemeint, komm, lass es uns vielleicht bitte so machen, wie auf europäischer Niveau auch, nämlich dass man im Halbfinale nicht mehr aufgrund einer Gelbsperre das Finale verpassen kann, dass im Finale vielleicht im Idealfall die Besten mit dabei sind. Aber gut, ist halt die Regel so. Und der ging in den gestern gegen Juve ab. Denn in der ersten Hälfte hat er es so wirklich ohne klassische Neuen probiert. Da waren De Quetellare, Luckmann und Cope Miners. Die drei Offensiven, keine Anhaltspunkte gegeben. Bremer konnte sich an keinem wirklich orientieren. Aber sie hatten halt auch keine Durchschlagskraft. Und dann hat er in der Pause gewechselt, hat De Quetellare rausgenommen, hat Thuré gebracht, den 30-Millionen-Mann, der ja vor der Saison aus Spanien gekommen war, der monatelang verletzt war, aber jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch Tore gemacht hat, den Schwung gekommen ist, jetzt auch ein richtig guter Djokov von der Bank war. Und den hat er halt da ins Zentrum reingestellt, aber da muss man sagen, den hat Bremer aufgefressen. Also da, das ist ja auch nicht die typische Position für Thuré, der liebt es ja auch ein bisschen mehr, mit Tempo zu kommen über außen, so Chiesa-mäßig. Und gestern musste er halt dann für die Mannschaft quasi da ins Zentrum rein. Und da hat man halt die ganze Klasse von Bremer gesehen. Aber das war jetzt wirklich, muss man sagen, in den letzten Wochen das einzige Spiel von Atalanta, das nicht gestimmt hat, sag ich mal. Denn die europäischen Auftritte zuletzt, also ihr Weg ins Finale, die waren mehr als beeindruckend. Und auch in der Liga haben sie sich jetzt wunderbar an die Ausgangsposition gepasst. Ihnen fehlt noch ein Sieg, um die Champions League fix zu machen. Plus haben sie auch noch die Möglichkeit, eh durch den Europa League Sieg, also sie haben noch zwei Wege in die Champions League, haben sogar noch ein Nachholspiel in der Hinterhand. Also ich glaube, da wird nichts mehr passieren. Und ja, jetzt können wir gerne mal drauf schauen, was Leverkusen da erwartet. Dann da erwartet sie einiges.
Weil ja, also wir alle bekommen natürlich die Stärke von Leverkusen mit. Noch kein Spiel verloren generell und damit eben auf europäischem Erfolgskurs. Aber allein in der Europa League auch Atalanta. Nur ein Spiel verloren, das war das Rückspiel gegen Liverpool, wo man ja mit dem 3-0 schon eine sehr gute Ausgangsposition hat.
Genau und also, ich meine, dieses Liverpool-Spiel an der Anfield Road, ich glaube, das hat Gasperini auch gesagt, das geht ja sowieso in die Vereinsgeschichte ein. Sie haben ja schon mal an Anfield Road gewonnen, damals noch in der Champions League von ein paar Jahren. Das war zu Covid-Zeiten ohne Fans. Dann eben wie gesagt jetzt Marseille. Das Rückspiel war wirklich mehr als souverän. Und sie haben ja auch davor Sporting rausgenommen. Und Sporting hat sich gerade erst zum portugiesischen Meister gekürt. Also Atalanta, wirklich die europäische Dimension von Atalanta, die wir schon vor ein paar Jahren auch in der Champions League, glaube ich, sehr viele sehr angenehm gesehen haben. Atalanta ist im Prinzip die italienische Mannschaft, die am gemachtesten, sage ich mal, für den europäischen Fußball ist. Also diese Intensität, diese Körperlichkeit. Auch gestern, Atalanta hat 11 Saisonspiele mehr als Juve absolviert. Das war gestern ihr 52. Saisonspiel schon. Die spielen seit Ende Februar im 3-Tages-Rhythmus. Also durch die Europa League, dann auch durch die 2 Coppa Italia Halbfinals. Die hatten noch ein Nachholspiel in der Woche. Die spielen wirklich seit Monaten, alle 3 Tage. Aber die halten die Intensität hoch. Du merkst keinen Abfall. Diese Körperlichkeit, die Gasperini da über Jahre implementiert hat und die Spieler wie Cobmann oder der Rohn perfekt verkörpern. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, ich glaube auch, dass Leverkusen auf dem Papier, allein durch diese ungeschlagen Serie und als deutscher Meister, als Favorit reingeht, aber ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass Atalanta vieles hat, was Leverkusen Probleme bereiten kann. Nämlich genau diese Intensität, diese Körperlichkeit auf allen Ebenen. Dieses Mann orientierte, wirklich dieses nach vorne verteidigen. Ich glaube, es wird ein sehr heißes Finale. Und wie gesagt, für Gasperini, der jetzt in seinem achten Jahr ist, wäre es halt auch einfach die Krönung. Dass er wahnsinnig viel hinterlassen hat oder hinterlassen wird, wann immer es dann auch zu Ende sein sollte, das steht ja eh schon fest. Aber jetzt ist es halt wirklich auch in der Zeit, da mal Silberware dafür zu ernten. Und nochmal, der Fokus von Atalanta war auch ganz klar formuliert, ist auf diesem Europa League-Finale in einer Woche. Und ich muss sagen, ich freue mich sehr drauf.
Kann er denn rotieren?
Ja, das ist es ja auch.
Kurz Champions League Qualifikation, die nur nicht ganz sicher ist.
Das ist ja der Punkt auch, wenn man sich zum Beispiel gestern angeschaut hat, wenn du dir mal die Breite im Atalanta-Kader mittlerweile anschaust. Also Atalanta ist halt auch, die haben halt auch als Verein wahnsinnig viel richtig in diesen letzten Jahren gemacht. Ich habe nochmal extra nachgeschaut, die haben seit 8 Jahren schreiben, die positive Bilanzen. Seit 8 Jahren. Und wenn du dir den vergangenen Sommer anschaust, die holen Bilal für knapp 30 Millionen, die holen Skamaka für 5 oder 26 Millionen. Also die können jetzt auch was leisten. Warum? Weil sie Heulund an United für 70 oder 80 verkauft haben. Also das machen die ja nicht auf Pump. Wir hatten ja heute schon ein paar Vereine, die auch sehr viel Geld ausgeben, wo man aber nicht weiß, wo das Geld herkommt. Aber die erwirtschaften das selbst, machen das clever.
Durch Corona hindurch muss man noch das wissen.
Das auch noch. Dazu investieren sie auch in Stadienausbau. Da wird ja dauernd gerade gearbeitet. Also es wird auch in Kürze fertig sein. Ihr Trainingszentrum in Singonia ist auf dem perfekten Stand. Also dieses ganze Geld, das sie sich jetzt erwirtschaftet haben, geht nicht nur in die Mannschaft rein, sondern wirklich auch in die Struktur. Also Atalanta ist da wirklich ein Vorzeigeklub. Und deswegen, wie du eben sagst, allein wenn du dir die Offensive anschaust, also er hat die Möglichkeit, er hat Skamaka, Lukman, de Quetellare, der eben eine herausragende Saison spielt, nachdem es letztes Jahr bei Milan überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Allein Skamaka, de Quetellare und Coop Miners haben jeweils 22 Scorer-Punkte in dieser Saison schon. Also Tore jeweils, die haben drei 22 Scorer-Punkte. Ich glaube, Coop Miners hat 15 plus 7, de Quetellare 12 plus 9 und Skamaka 16 plus 6 oder so. Also dann kommen noch, in der Hinterhand hat er dann noch Tore eben, der eben der teuerste Mann war, der halt einfach lang verletzt war. Dann hat der Mirancuk noch, der auch eine gute Saison spielt. Dann hat der Pašalić noch, der diese Halbposition spielen kann. Also es gibt in der Serie A, würde ich sagen, im offensiven Bereich, keinen Verein, der so tief aufgestellt ist. Also das, um zu zeigen eben, dass sie auch über Jahre sich sozusagen jetzt in eine Position gebracht haben, eben nicht von einzelnen Spielern abhängig zu sein. Und dementsprechend, ja, ich habe gestern auch schon mal so ein bisschen vorausgeschaut. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass Xabi Alonso die Variante wählt, wie gegen die Roma, vielleicht wieder ohne Mittelstürmer, weil eben, wie gesagt, das gegen diese ganzen schnellen mit Wirts, mit Fimpong, mit Adli. Weil eben, wenn du Atalanta keinen Anhaltspunkt gibst, dann lockst du sie logisch auch raus durch dieses Mannorientiere. Und dann hat logisch Fimpong, das Tempo von Fimpong oder auch von Wirts, ist logisch nochmal eine andere Qualität. Also, da wird Atalanta extrem aufpassen müssen. Aber trotzdem glaube ich auch, dass Atalanta selbst Leverkusen, das haben wir gegen die Roma auch gesehen, die Leverkusen-Defensive, die ist nicht so sattelfest, sage ich mal. Da kannst du dir schon auch was erspielen. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass Atalanta da viel über den Rhythmus, über die Körperlichkeit, über die Intensität schaffen wird. Ederson spielt eine großartige Saison, das haben wir ja schon thematisiert auch hier. Basalic hat jetzt auch wieder aus der zweiten Reihe kommen und getroffen. Also die haben viele Möglichkeiten. Das sind schwer auszurechnen.
Interessant, ich meine, wer die Bundesligapartien von Leverkusen gesehen hat, der würde jetzt nicht sagen, es ist so einfach, gegen Leverkusen ein Tor zu schießen.
Nein, das ist nichts. Aber schau dir mal die Roma an.
Genau, du hast es hier.
Ich finde gerade das Roma-Rückspiel, ich meine, die Roma verliert das Hinspiel gegen diese Leverkusen mit 0 zu 2. Wer hatte damit gerechnet, dass die in Leverkusen nochmal ins Spiel zurückkommen? Klar lief da auch vieles für die Roma. Die Chancenverwertung von Leverkusen war nicht gut. Zwila hält überragend bis zu diesem neuen Moment, sage ich mal, in der 81. Klar hatten sie auch ein gewisses Glück, aber sie waren plötzlich wieder dran. Und sie hatten ja auch andere Chancen. Ich glaube, da war doch Pellegrini, Kopfball und so. Also ich glaube schon, dass du die Leverkusen abwehrst, dass du dir Probleme bereiten kannst. Und da hat Atalanta auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Wir haben jetzt die ganzen zentralen Offensiven angesprochen. Viel geht bei Atalanta ja auch über die Außen, wo eben immer wieder eine Seite überladen wird, wo dann auch sich die Angreifer da rausfallen lassen, Überzahl schaffen, wo dann auch die Verteidiger aus der Dreierkette mit vorne mit sich mit einschalten, eine gute Strafraumbesetzung. Also Atalanta zu dechiffrieren ist nicht einfach. Juve hat es gestern vorgemacht. Aber Juve hatte halt auch die ideale Voraussetzung, nehmen wir das früher 1 zu 0. Und dann auch wirklich diese defensive Stabilität, die ich mal sagen muss, die jetzt vielleicht auch bei aller Kritik an Juve, aber wenn Juve das so liefert wie gestern, so viele Mannschaften in Europa, glaube ich, können das nicht leisten, 90 Minuten plus so tiefstehend konzentriert zu verteidigen.
Und Atalanta hat wahrscheinlich seinen Gäste-Kontingent schon ausverkauft fürs Finale.
Also ich glaube, da kommt die ganze Stadt mit.
Ja, aber Leverkusen hat ja noch 10.800 von 12.000 Karten, die bis das verkauft wurde vor zwei Tagen gemeldet. Es ist einfach eine kleine Szene und anscheinend reicht nicht mal ein Finale und Direktflüge von Düsseldorf nach Dublin.
Okay, aber das ist echt beeindruckend, weil Atalanta ist auch ein Bergamo mit 120.000 Einwohnern. Das ist ja auch das Besondere. Das fand ich sehr schön von Gasperini. Das hat er nach dem Halbfinale gegen Marseille, da hat er auch so ein Plädoyer gemeint. Viele in Uefa sind jetzt vielleicht nicht froh darüber, dass das Finale Leverkusen gegen Atalanta heißt. Aber es ist halt auch ein Zeichen dafür, dass nicht nur die ganz, ganz Großen mit den Millionen Followern und Millionen Anhängern, sondern der Fußball ist halt auch für die da, die einfach vielleicht aus einer kleineren Struktur heraus gut arbeiten. Er hat auch nochmal das Beispiel aufgemacht mit hier Superliga. Alle reden von Superliga, Superliga, aber dafür sind es halt auch Standorte wie diese, die sich das halt einfach arbeiten. Also in Bergamo ist Ausnahmezustand. Das war ja, viel erinnert sich ja vielleicht noch an die Szene der Champions League und also ich möchte gar nicht wissen, wie viel von diesen 120.000 da nächsten Mittwoch mit in Dublin sind. Denn Atalanta ist halt auch wirklich ein, ja wie soll man sagen, mehr als ein Aushängestil dieser Stadt. Also Atalanta und Bergamo sind unfassbar eng miteinander verwoben. Da war ja auch die tragische Geschichte mit Corona, die diesen schlimmen Ausgangspunkt in Italien hatte. Das hat den Verein und die Stadt nochmal mehr zusammengeschweißt. Und dementsprechend, also da fiebert wirklich eine ganze Stadt, eine ganze Region mit. Und mal schauen, ob es für Atalanta das Happy End gibt.
Wir werden sehen, aber behaltet all das, was Christian gesagt hat, mal im Hinterkopf, wenn ihr dieses Finale vielleicht seht. Also A, seid nicht überrascht, sollte ein anderes Team auch Fußball spielen können. Und vielleicht kann man dann auch, sollte das jetzt Leverkusen wirklich verlieren, selbst aus einer deutschen Brille heraus. Das vielleicht mal gönnen, dass es auch andere Fußballstandorte gibt. Sorry, ist jetzt kein Juve 1-0.
Nee, nee, nee. Das ist was anderes.
So ihr zwei, meine Güte. Jetzt habe ich uns wieder hier lange rausgelabert. Haben wir eigentlich noch Awards? Habe ich gar nicht mit euch darüber gesprochen.
Ja, haben wir die.
Dann legt er Christian vor.
Soll ich mal loslegen? Ja, der Name fiel schon. Also ganz klar Thiago Motta. Du hast es angesprochen. Bologna hat am vergangenen Wochenende die Champions League klar gemacht. Standesgemäß doch ein 2-0 in Neapel. Klar, Neapel, auch eine eigene Sendung wert. Aber trotzdem auswärts beim nicht mehr Meister. Vor wenigen Wochen haben sie das direkt gegen die Roma in Rom gewonnen mit 3 zu 1. Also die Saison. Jetzt sind sie Punkte gleich mit Juve. Jetzt am Wochenende steht übrigens das Direkturale mit Juve noch aus. Sie können auch noch Dritter werden. Sie haben es jetzt auch selbst in der Hand. Sensationell. Wir haben Gott sei Dank schon zwei, drei Mal darüber gesprochen. Und jetzt haben sie es wirklich, kann ich mich noch erinnern, Max, wie du schon vor ein paar Wochen gemeint hast, ach, wäre das schön, wenn Bologna in die Champions League käme. Sie haben es eiskalt durchgezogen. Ja, wirklich. Also auf allen Ebenen beeindruckend. Die Euphorie ist riesig in Bologna. Bologna ist ja auch eine alte eingesessene, eine ganz historische Fußballstadt. Früher hat Roberto Baggio da gespielt, Pepe Signori. Ich glaube, seit 60 Jahren waren die jetzt nicht mehr für einen Landesmeisterpokal qualifiziert. Also egal, was da im Sommer passiert, auch wenn Thiago Mota gehen sollte, wo einiges darauf hinläutet, da werden auch ein, zwei Spieler gehen. Aber, und da das Schöne dran, es heißt, dass falls Thiago Mota geht, Maurizio Sarri in der Verlosung ist. Und das, finde ich, muss ich sagen, ja wirklich, nicht nur Fußballromantisch, sondern wirklich auch von der Fußballidee, die Thiago Mota jetzt ja da implementiert hat. Wenn es einen gäbe, der diese Art vielleicht nochmal aufnehmen und weiterführen könnte, dann wäre es Sarri. Also wenn es so kommen sollte, wenn wirklich Thiago Mota geht und Sarri kommt, ich würde meinen Haken sofort dahinter setzen.
Christian Bernhard approved. Und das können nicht alle von sich sagen. Fabian, wer ist dein MVP?
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, ob Nils in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt hat, aber ich würde gerne wieder einen Malagenio nennen, und zwar Esco. Er spielt nach wie vor überragend. Er ist nach wie vor Spielentscheid für Betis. Er hat jetzt in die Europa League geführt. Und auch Nationaltrainer de la Fuente hat jetzt tatsächlich in einem Interview angekündigt. Er überlegt sich dann tatsächlich, den besten Scorer im Mittelfeld in Spanien dann mitzunehmen zur EM. Ich finde die Geschichte von Isco echt überragend. Eigentlich, der ja schon komplett weg war. Die Geschichte mit Union Berlin, die in die Hosen gegangen ist, hätte Union Berlin anscheinend doch ganz gut getan. Die beißen sich jetzt wirklich in den Arsch. Was der abzieht dieses Jahr ist unfassbar. Wie der die Spieler stehen lässt, was er für drohende Macht vorbereitet. Er ist Spieler des Monats im April geworden, er ist in der Liga absolut zurecht. Wie gesagt, er ist nach wie vor an Toren beteiligt. Er zielt sich selbst auch jetzt am Wochenende wieder. Ich glaube, es wird darauf hinauslaufen, dass wir ihn auch bei der EM sehen werden. Deswegen ist ISKU absolut mein MVP.
Stark, da freue ich mich auch schon drauf. Da gibt es auch Spanien gegen Italien in der Vorrunde.
Ja, allerdings.
Oh Gott, ich muss mich vorbereiten. Ich kriege schon wieder Stress. Ich muss danach arbeiten.
Ansatz an Hero. Pantaleo Corvino. Sag vielleicht nicht allen was. Sportdirektor Legende. 74 Jahre alt mittlerweile. Lecce hat sich schon am vorletzten Spiel, also drei Spiele vor Schluss, die Klasse gehalten. In Italien. Schauen wir mal am Ende der Saison. Die sind noch wahnsinnig eng im Abstiegskampf. Aber Lecce ist schon durch, kann nicht mehr eingeholt werden. Und das mit dem abstandgünstigsten Kader der Liga. 15 Millionen brutto, heißt es. Ja, kostet der Kader 15. Also anscheinend auch direkte Abstiegskonkurrenten haben teilweise fast ein Doppel zu hohen. Ja, finanzielle Möglichkeiten. Und der Mann dahinter ist eben Pantaleo Corvino. 74 Jahre alt. Der hat Lecce schon, jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob euch die Namen noch was sagen. Sagen euch die Namen? Micholi oder Cevanton noch was. Auf jeden Fall Mirko Vucinic vielleicht noch. Der war ja später auch bei Juve. Die hat da alle. Micholi auf jeden Fall. Genau, ganz ein kleiner Zaubermaus mit Diego Armando Maradona-Tattoo auf der Wade. Stilvoll, echt großartig. Und die hat er schon vor 25 Jahren, war er da schon bei Lecce, hat all diese Leute geholt. Er war es, der Vlaović zur Fiorentina geholt hat. Er hat bei der Fiorentina schon, das war die Zeit, als sie noch Champions League gegen die Bayern gespielt haben. Da war Prandelli Trainer, das war so um 2.8 herum. Er hat Luca Toni nach Florenz geholt, er hat Cilardino nach Florenz geholt, er hat Montolivo nach Florenz geholt. Also ist eigentlich seit Jahren der Sportdirektor mit der größten, wie soll ich sagen, mit der längsten Erfolgsgeschichte. Und der Mann ist jetzt seit vier Jahren auch wieder bei Lecce, sind in seine Heimat zurückgekommen, hat sie erst in die erste Liga wieder hochgeholt, jetzt mit dem günstigsten Kader drin gehalten. Da gab es ja vor Wochen auch diese Geschichte, die mussten den Trainer entlassen, da wäre es er, weil der einen gegnerischen Spieler gestoßen hatte. Das haben die auch aufgefangen und hat auch einen richtigen Mann geholt, Gotti, der die jetzt über die Ziellinie gebracht hat. Und eine Zahl noch dazu, weil wir die 15 Millionen, vergangenen Sommer hatte er Jülmand, den dänischen Nationalspieler, für 20 Millionen nach Portugal zu Sporting verkauft. Das war der teuerste Verkauf der Geschichte. Und allein mit diesem Verkauf hat er sozusagen die kompletten Personalkosten für dieses Jahr plus noch ein paar Millionen obendrauf. Also der Mann weiß, wie man sich im, ja nicht nur im Abstiegskampf, weil er hat es ja auch bei der Fiorentina schon bewiesen, der weiß, wie man vielleicht auch mit wenigen Mitteln sehr, sehr viel hoch, sehr viel rausholt.
Stark. Ich habe kurz versucht, das in Bezug zu setzen zur Bundesliga. Auch 15 Millionen Euro Personaletat hatte damals im Zweitliga-Jahr der VfL Bochum. Jetzt sind sie auf 19. Dann denkt man sich so, naja, dann ist es ja gar nicht so beeindruckend. Aber jetzt lese ich euch mal ein paar andere vor. HSV, 40 Millionen Personaletat, Fortuna Düsseldorf, 24 Millionen Personaletat. Also jetzt alles lauten offizielle DFL-Zahlen und so weiter.
Also ich finde, 15 ist schon echt. Ich meine, das sind ja immer Schätzungen, ist ja klar. Aber wenn es auch nur annähernd stimmt, dann ist das wirklich... Die haben letztes Jahr nicht nur Jülmann verloren, im Sommer auch Umtiti, der damals, der vom Barca dahin kam, eine herausragende Saison gespielt hat. Und haben einfach clever eingekauft, weil Corvino Nässen davon hat. Und während hier Verona, Cali, Reudinese, Fosinone, Empoli, Sassuolo alle noch zittern, wird in Lettscher schon seit dem vergangenen Sonntag gefeiert.
Sehr schön. Ich habe den perfekten Bundesligavergleich mal wiedergefunden, weil nur darum geht es in der Liga.
Absolut.
Heidenheim. Etat 15 Millionen. Und wer hat es in der Bundesliga geschafft, dass er nicht mehr zittern muss und andere noch zittern? Also quasi das italienische Heidenheim. Kannst du das bitte etablieren, dass auch in der EAA so drüber berichtet wird?
Ja, ich habe mir einen ausgepickt, mit dem keiner viel gesetzt hat, nämlich den aktuellen Trainer von Celta de Vigo, Claudio Chiraldes. Der ist erst 36 Jahre alt, kam von der zweiten Mannschaft von Celta de Vigo und hat den Trainerstuhl übernommen vor ein paar Wochen von Rafa Benitez, der eigentlich zu Celta de Vigo jetzt in der Jubiläumssaison, ich weiß nicht, ob es das 100-jährige Jubiläum oder das 120-jährige, irgendein tolles Jubiläum haben sie dieses Jahr. Sorry, dass ich nicht genau weiß, wie viele Jahre das ist. Aber er sollte eigentlich Celta de Vigo wieder zu neuen Ruhm verhelfen. Und es sah ganz lange und böse nach Abstieg aus. Dann wurde Benitez vor die Tür gesetzt und man hat sich für eine interne Lösung entschieden, eben für diesen Claudio Chiraldes, 36 Jahre, war vorher Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, ist Galizia, ist sogar jünger als einer seiner besten Spieler, nämlich Yago Aspas. Und hat es aber geschafft. Es ist noch nicht mathematisch soweit, aber er hat tatsächlich wichtige Punkte eingefahren im Abstiegskampf. Sie sind jetzt fünf Punkte drüber bei zwei ausstehenden Spielen. Es sieht sehr gut aus, vor allen Dingen nach dem gestrigen Sieg gegen Athletic Bilbao. Da waren sie schon 0-1 hinten und haben noch das Spiel gedreht, mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Unwahrscheinlich wichtig, sonst wären sie jetzt mit Cadiz tatsächlich in einem herben Zweikampf gesteckt, was den letzten Abstiegsplatz anbelangt. Dementsprechend muss ich sagen, Hut ab vor dem Mann, der seine erste Profi-Laufstation hat, mit nur 36 Jahren, in einer extrem schwierigen Situation. Der macht das sehr ordentlich. Dementsprechend könnte auch gut sein, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren noch ein bisschen was von dem jungen Mann hören.
Ich liebe die Anzang Hero-Kategorie. Da kommt wirklich die interessante Geschichte. Lass mal was von Sportdirektor von Lecce über den neuen Interimstrainer von Celta Vigo. Mega gut, hätte ich schon viel früher einführen müssen hier in der Liga Tour. So, den Moment des Spieltags haben wir noch.
Ja, da haben wir ja ein bisschen Input bekommen von unseren italienischen Zuschauern, Zuhörern. Alessandro, Spitzname Billy, Costa Curta, sagt vielleicht einigen noch was, AC Milan, Verteidigerlagende in den Jahren mit Parese, mit Maldinia, eine der beeindruckendsten defensiven Europas gebildet und der mittlerweile sein Geld auch als TV-Experte verdient und am vergangenen Wochenende war er da mit vollem Körpereinsatz dabei, nämlich es ging auch um das Milan-Spiel und da wollte er eine Szene nochmal vor dem großen Bildschirm im TV-Studio eindrucksvoll nachzeichnen und hat eine Rettungsschätzung, eine Defensiv- Rettungstat nachgespielt, nämlich so eine eingesprungene Grätsche und in dem Moment, wo er es macht, zack, greift er sich hinten an den Oberschenkel, ist es beim Herrn Costa-Curta reingefahren. Sie sind auch sofort in die Werbung gegangen, das ist auch witzig. Also es ist nichts Schlimmes passiert, aber er hat sich logisch eine Zerrung zugezogen und kleiner mit einem Lächeln zwinkern. Er passt sich da mit der Milan-Saison an, denn da waren ja auch mehr oder weniger alle Verteidiger, sowohl Ciao, als auch Tumori, als auch Quier wochenlang teilweise Kalulu, wochenlang monatelang verletzt, als auch Costa-Curta. Obwohl er nicht mehr das Milan-Trikot trägt, hat er sich irgendwie mit vollem Einsatz da auch in diese jetzt am Ende nochmal da gut in die Milan-Reihe eingereiht.
Sehr schön. Ja, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank da auch an den Input, den wir da bekommen haben. Ich werde es nachreichen bzw. jetzt kann ich es noch schnell raussuchen. Ich finde es leider nicht mehr. Ich werde es verlinken in den Show Notes. Herzlichen Dank auf jeden Fall dafür, dass ihr euch da gemeldet habt und dann hat Fabian noch einen Moment des Spiels.
Ja, wie gesagt, in der Liga ist ja ein bisschen die Luft raus, deswegen kann ich jetzt gar nicht so mit einem richtig tollen emotionalen Moment dienen. Vielleicht zwei Anmerkungen zu den letzten zwei Spieltagen, weil wir haben ja gerade unter der Woche gerade einen Spieltag laufen. Real Madrid marschiert gerade mit einem 4-0- und einem 5-0-Sieg nochmal so durch die letzten Ligaspiele. Also, die schonen sich, die lassen ihre zweite Gilde spielen und die knipsen natürlich auch schön. Da möchte sich jeder noch fürs Champions League-Finale empfehlen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine krasse Momentaufnahme. Und was ich ganz witzig fand, war nach dem Spiel von Mallorca, die ja noch im Abstiegskampf stecken, ich glaube mit 36 Punkte, 4 Punkte nur vor Cadiz, da wurde nach der Pressekonferenz der Trainer gefragt, ob er sich denn dann das Spiel von Cadiz auch anschauen würde. Javier Aguirre, der Mexikaner, der sehr amüsante Pressekonferenzen gibt und immer sehr witzige Kommentare und sehr ehrliche Kommentare abgibt. Und der meinte, er glaubt nicht, weil es hängt alles von seiner Frau ab, von Sylvia, weil er muss wahrscheinlich ins Kino oder er muss wieder Wasser oder Milch für sie kaufen oder sonst irgendwas, also er wird es wahrscheinlich nicht anschauen können. Ja, ist ja auch egal, er muss sich ja dann auf sein Team konzentrieren und so weiter, hat dann wieder den Bogen so ein bisschen gespannt. Aber es hängt im Hause Aguirre natürlich alles von der Ehefrau ab.
Oh, ein bisschen antiquiertes Rollenbild, das dann auch so zu thematisieren. Aber gut, wir nehmen es hin. The Butcher war derjenige, der den Hinweis hinterlassen hat. Nee, war es auch nicht. Warum gibt es denn hier so viele Ligatur-Threads? Ich weiß nicht, ich werde es mal rausgesucht haben. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr, das hat wieder sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich habe wieder sehr viel gelernt. Das ist der Vorteil, wenn man nur zu dritt ist, dass wir richtig plaudern konnten, das war sehr nett. Herzlichen Dank an Fabian Pakulat, wie immer. Und vielen Dank, Christian Bernhard. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Danke, Max, danke Fabian, großen Spaß gemacht.
Aber wirklich, und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich natürlich auch für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support. Ich moderiere hier jetzt einfach schon ab und ich werde auch das Outro spielen, denn stand jetzt, weiß ich immer noch nicht, wahrscheinlich wird es jetzt doch nicht geklappt haben, dass wir noch über die Premier League sprechen. Es tut mir sehr leid, es hängt mit der verfügbarkeit, terminlichen Verfügbarkeit der möglichen Experten hier zusammen und da könnt ihr ja auch nichts für. Deswegen moderiere ich jetzt hier ab, falls noch was danach kommt, dann werdet ihr es am Timecode gerade merken. Ich danke sehr, sehr herzlich allen Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützern des Rasenfunks. In diesem Fall möchte ich mich bedanken bei Kunibert, bei Stefan, bei Markus aus Heidenheim, bei Scotty Guinness, bei Benjamin und bei Guido. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangen und haben uns unterstützt. Geht via Paypal, Kreditkarte, Direktüberweisung und so weiter. Einen Hinweis möchte ich aber noch machen, wenn euch EM-Coverage interessiert, von der ich selber noch nicht weiß, wie sie aussehen wird. Aber was ich weiß, ist, ihr müsst dafür den Rasenfunk Nationalteams Feed abonnieren. Alle EM-Sendungen zu den deutschen Spielen, Vorschau, Rückblick, alles wird dort erscheinen. Auch das werde ich verlinken. In diesem Sinne, bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.